know Microsoft is a kid that you see him
trying hard but he just don't have that
athleticism you know he's on the
baseball team but he don't have like you
know you got the Derrick Jeeps
everything come easy to them you know
and they're getting the accolades and
they're trying but he trying hard too
you know sometimes he stumbles like he's
running to the base and he's going real
hard because he practiced all week but
he tripped right at the end you know
like he get called out you know a
Microsoft is always trying
this is all on you bro I told you make
your date
30 games you showed
10 of them don't got dates
that's a hell of a l bro that is a hell
of an L I don't and and I don't care
don't tell me oh you know we we took the
time out for the 30 to the you know it
was Todd ready before it was Todd ready
last year right
and everybody knew
going in that you put a Target on your
back now I know you're gonna say oh